make a damn schedule and stick to it
it's not a bloody prison I've told
people to learn to use a schedule and
people often hate schedules because they
act as their own tyrants right they say
we have to do this unpleasant thing and
then here's another unpleasant thing you
have to do and then you have to do this
unpleasant thing and you do that for
about three days and you think I'm not
doing that you know and you fall off the
wagon that isn't what you're supposed to
do with the schedule you're supposed to
use it to design the days that you would
like to have if you were taking care of
yourself and so some of that is you know
you wake up in the morning and you think
here's five things I have to do that if
I don't do my life will be worse it's
like paying bills for example or or
taking out the garbage it's like you
have to do those because otherwise
things degenerate so you got to put some
of those in the schedule because
otherwise tomorrow is worse than today
and that's a bad trajectory but you also
want to build in things you know you've
got to act in some sense like you're
dealing with a relatively recalcitrant
nine-year-old it's like so well here's
some things you you have to do but
here's some things that if you do you
could reward yourself with and if you
get the balance there between obligation
and reward right then you'll find that
you're motivated to do the things and
and that's what you want to do you want
to do that so it's sustainable across
days and weeks and months you got to
treat yourself like a good boss would
treat a valued employee and not like a
tyrant would treat a slave because the
slave will Rebel and you know people say
well I I don't follow through on my
plans it's like well a they're probably
not very well formulated and maybe
you're doing them because of an external
moral obligation or something not really
your plans right and B you're acting
like a tyrant and a slave and that's a
bad relationship to have with yourself
so that's the Golden Rule right treat
other people as you would like to be
treated it works both ways you also
treat yourself like you treat other
people properly so that's a necessary
thing and often people don't do that but
the scheduling is really important the
question always is why do do something
because doing nothing is easy you just
sit there and you don't do anything
that's real easy the question is why
would you ever do anything and the
answer that has to be because you've
determined by some means that it's
worthwhile and then the next question
might be well where should you look for
worthwhile things and one would be well
you could consult your own temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan you
need a family you need friends like you
don't need to have all these things but
you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for time outside of work attention to
your mental and physical health Etc you
know those are that's what life is about
and if you don't have any of those
things well then all you've got left is
misery and suffering so that's that's a
bad deal for you so you should be doing
is trying to figure out who it is that
you're trying to be right you aim at
that and then use everything you learn
as a means of building that person that
you want to be okay number one specify
your damn goals because how are you
going to hit something if you don't know
what it is that is isn't going to happen
and often people won't specify their
goals too because they don't like to
specify conditions for failure so if you
keep yourself all vague and foggy which
is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well then you
don't know when you fail and people
might say well I really don't want to
know when I fail because that's painful
so I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail that's fine except you'll fail all
the time then you just won't know it
until you've failed so badly that you're
done and that can easily happen by the
time you're 40. so I would recommend
that you don't let that happen so that's
willful blindness right you could have
known but you chose not to okay so once
you get your goal structure set up you
think okay if I can have this life looks
like that might be worth living okay so
then what do you do then you turn down
to the micro routine it's like okay well
this is what I'm aiming for how does
that instantiate itself day to day week
to week month to month and that's where
something like a schedule can be
unbelievably useful Google Calendar make
a damn schedule and stick to it okay so
what's the rule with the schedule it's
not a bloody prison that's the first
thing that people do wrong they say well
I don't like to have follow a schedule
it's like well what kind of schedule are
you setting up well I have to do this
then I have to do this then I have to do
this you know and then I just go play
video games because who wants to do all
these things that I have to do it's like
wrong set the damn schedule up so that
you have the day you want that's the
trick it's like okay I've got tomorrow
if I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking what would it look
like well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy so maybe 20
of your day has to be responsibility and
obligation or maybe it's more than that
depending on how far behind you are but
even that you can you can ask yourself
okay well I've got these
responsibilities I have to schedule the
damn things in what's the right ratio of
responsibility to reward and you can ask
yourself that just like you'd negotiate
with someone who is working for you okay
so I want you to work tomorrow and you
might say okay well what are you going
to do for me that makes it likely that
I'll work for you well you could ask
yourself that you know maybe you do an
hour of responsibility and then you play
a video game for 15 minutes I don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
have to negotiate with yourself and not
tyrannize yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life and and that's how
you make the schedule it's like and then
you look at the day and you think well
if I had that day that'd be good great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70 percent accuracy but that
beats the hell out of zero right and if
you hit it even with 50 accuracy another
rule is well aim for 51 the next week or
50 and a half percent for God's sake or
because you're going to hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward so
that's one way that you can work on your
conscientiousness is a plan a life you'd
like to have and you do that partly by
having a little conversation with
yourself about as if you don't really
know who you are because you know what
you like you won't do what you're told
you won't do what you tell yourself to
do you must have noticed that it's like
you're a bad employee and a worse boss
and both of those work for you you don't
know what you want to do and then when
you tell yourself what to do you don't
do it anyways you should fire yourself
and find someone else to be but you know
my point is is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant so to speak you're someone that
you have to negotiate with and that's
and you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life to and that's hard for people
because they don't like themselves very
much so you know they're always like
cracking the Whip and then
procrastinating and cracking the Whip
and then procrastinating and it's like
God it's so boring and such a pathetic
way of spending your time and you know
what that's like because you probably
waste like six hours a day and I think
we did an economic calculation about
that a while back right your time's
probably worth 50 bucks an hour
something like that I mean you're not
getting paid that now but you're young
and so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future so so let's say
it's 50 bucks an hour which is perfectly
reasonable so if you waste six hours a
day and you are then you're wasting
about two thousand dollars a week or
about a hundred thousand dollars a year
so like go ahead but that's what it's
costing you every hour and you need to
know what your damn time is worth so
let's say it's not 50 bucks it's 30.
whatever maybe it's a hundred it's
somewhere in that range one of the
things you should be asking yourself is
when you spend an hour was that well
what if I paid someone 50 bucks to have
had that hour and if the answer is no
it's like well maybe you should do
something else with your time and it
depends on whether or not you think that
your time's worthwhile but the funny
thing about not assuming that is if you
assume your time isn't worthwhile
what happens is you don't just sit
around sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility list Bliss what you do is
you suffer existentially and so make a
damn schedule